this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming service built by
all your favorite youtubers when you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
[Music]
if you've been subscribed to my channel
for a while you've probably seen several
of my videos on climate change
i periodically return to the topic when
new studies are published because it's
an important issue
as you're likely aware climate change
can be a very polarizing topic
get it polarizing polar ice caps never
mind the fact of the matter is that
every time this channel or anyone else
releases a video on the changing climate
a certain type of person comes out of
the woodwork to yell about ice ages
reversing poles and the solar minimum
now the easy thing to do is ignore those
people and just provide the new data
from relevant scientific studies
but i'm going to take a slightly
different approach this time today we
are going to look at some new findings
but we're also going to talk about why
you should care about the changing
climate regardless of what you think is
causing it
let's begin with the premise accepted by
the vast majority of global scientists
based on their research the earth is
experiencing higher than normal
temperatures
largely influenced by human activity
specifically the burning of fossil fuels
and the accumulation of high levels of
co2 in the atmosphere
these increased temperatures will cause
a destructive feedback loop
higher temperatures will melt more ice
which will release more greenhouse gases
which will further increase the
temperature and so on
as global average temperature rises
we'll see an increase in erratic and
violent weather conditions such as
hurricanes droughts and their byproducts
like flooding wildfires and the spread
of disease
obviously these things are all harmful
to human flourishing and should be
avoided if at all possible
the general consensus is pretty clear we
are already experiencing and will
continue to
experience climate-related fallout the
question that scientists are now trying
to answer is
just how sensitive is the climate to
increase levels of carbon dioxide
if they can zero in on a likely answer
we can better understand what to expect
in the coming decades a new
international study published in the
journal reviews of geophysics is the
most recent step in the search
organized by the world climate research
program and consisting of a team of
scientists from 10 different countries
the report titled an assessment of
earth's climate sensitivity using
multiple
lines of evidence has clarified our
understanding of just how much the
climate will warm if atmospheric co2
levels remain at double the
pre-industrial level
on the cusp of the industrial revolution
the planet's atmospheric co2
concentration measured 278 parts per
million
today two and a half centuries and
billions of tons of fossil fuels later
we have a concentration of 414 parts per
million
if the buildup of co2 continues at the
current rate we will reach 560 ppm by
2080
putting us at more than twice the
concentration of co2 prior to the
industrial revolution
the new report attempts to refine our
predictions of how those increased
levels will affect our climate
the study was conducted using three key
batches of evidence
first temperature measurements taken by
thermometers from the year 1850 when
significant coverage first became
available to the present
second evidence from ancient climate
records from the peak of the last ice
age around 20
000 years ago when co2 concentration was
lower than today
and from a period of warmer temperatures
around 4 million years ago when
concentration was higher
this evidence is obtained from the
makeup of gases trapped in ancient ice
cores
finally the study makes use of modern
observations such as satellite imagery
and advanced climate models that examine
the physics of interactions within the
climate system
these three lines of evidence gave the
researchers a basis from which they
could estimate with a higher degree of
certainty the long-term effect of an
increased concentration of co2 in the
atmosphere
so what did the team determine one of
their most significant findings is the
fact that by their assessment the
warming we've seen since pre-industrial
times would be all but impossible
without human activity
the rate of increase is simply too
dramatic to be caused solely by natural
forces
and clearly follows the increase in
human industry over the last two and a
half centuries
but as important as that assessment is
their other findings give us a greater
understanding of what level of warming
we can expect
for many years now the standard estimate
for warming has been between 1.5 and 4.5
degrees celsius
more recently the ipcc's fifth
assessment report gave this range a
likelihood of at least 66 percent
that meant that there was up to a 33
chance that the levels of warming would
be either above or below that range
thanks to this new study we can say with
confidence that the range has narrowed
to between 2.3 and 4.5 degrees
or perhaps even narrower this means the
lower end of the range has risen
significantly and the scientific
community is now more certain that the
warming effect will not be as small as
we had hoped
the likelihood of the new range remains
mostly the same around 66
probability with an 18 chance of hitting
the upper end of the estimate
a 5 chance of the warming remaining
below 2 degrees
and a 5 chance of it exceeding 5.7
degrees
showing a bunch of numbers is one thing
but in order to really get the point
across we need to look at how these
numbers apply to the real world
take the prolonged heat wave in the
siberian arctic for example
like most places siberia can get pretty
warm in the summer
but what we're seeing now this huge
increase in both the intensity and
duration of the heat wave is
unprecedented and according to the
authors of the study
represents unequivocal evidence of
climate change and that the record high
temperatures would be impossible without
human production of greenhouse gases
for the last six months
record-shattering temperatures in the
arctic have led to massive wildfires
generating huge plumes of smoke which
have been visible from space
with average temperatures reaching 5
degrees celsius over normal
even hitting 38 degrees celsius the
highest temperature ever recorded in the
arctic circle
it's clear that what we're seeing in
siberia and other parts of the arctic is
a consequence of the changing climate
for those of you thinking so what this
doesn't affect me
yes it does dramatic changes in the
arctic can have serious ramifications
the world over
for example in the uk there are six main
weather systems
four of them come directly from the
arctic or polar regions
extreme cold and blizzards intense
rainfall and flooding heat waves
they can all be caused by disturbances
in the fragile systems of the arctic
this leads us back to the vicious cycle
i mentioned earlier with the arctic
literally on fire and heating up at an
unprecedented pace
we'll see a greater reduction in sea ice
which will release more greenhouse gases
further exacerbating the problem and
leading to more extreme weather around
the world
this all seems very dire and it is but
as promised
let's talk about why this should matter
to you even if you don't believe humans
have anything to do with climate change
if you're out for a walk and someone is
driving their car straight at you and
you're clearly going to be run over
what would you do you'd do everything in
your power to avoid being run over right
does it matter whether the driver is
purposely trying to kill you or if his
brakes were out
no because the end result is undesirable
either way
the things that led up to the moment of
you having to avoid a car
shouldn't factor into your consideration
of how to respond the same is true of
climate fallout
regardless of whether you think climate
change is entirely normal or
dramatically worsened by human activity
the end result is apparent we're seeing
massive increases in violent weather
more frequent hurricanes unseasonably
hot weather droughts wildfires floods
extended summers which allow the
proliferation of disease-carrying
insects the death of crops as the
region's climate begins to change
all of these things demand solutions
whether we humans are to blame or not
why allow ourselves to be hit by a car
if we can take steps to avoid it
there's no such thing as a partisan
thermometer and the fact that the earth
is warming is just that
a fact we can squabble over causes
though we really shouldn't when 97
of climate scientists agree that the
current predicament is caused largely by
human activity
or we can get to work on finding
solutions to adapt to our changing
climate
as far as solutions go we need to be
careful not to rely too heavily on
technocratic fixes
and focus on the main problem areas just
about everyone
even climate change skeptics can agree
that co2 is a potent warming agent and
we currently produce a lot of it
if we can dramatically reduce the amount
of greenhouse gases we release into the
atmosphere
that would help prevent a runaway
warming effect that could result in
catastrophic consequences
that being said we need to be realistic
we've already set in motion a scenario
which will inevitably release more
warming agents that have been trapped in
ice for thousands or millions of years
we need to end our reliance on fossil
fuels but we also need to prepare for
the now
unpreventable fallout that will cause
serious damage to the world's at-risk
areas
already hot regions will face record
heatwaves and droughts which will
adversely affect food production the
continued warming and acidification of
the world's oceans will destroy fragile
ecosystems like coral reefs
and threaten fish populations which many
groups heavily rely on for food
islands and coastal regions are at risk
of flooding or complete submersion
i was recently in the marshall islands
to shoot a documentary and everywhere we
looked we could see evidence of climate
change
stretches of land that were once
habitable were now completely submerged
water rose up over stone barriers and
flooded streets houses had waves
literally knocking on their door
these are the communities that are at
the forefront of climate disaster
the world needs to take notice of these
places that function as the canary in
the coal mine
climate change will disrupt more than
just island nations and coastal regions
and we need to focus on building
infrastructure and mitigation measures
to help offset both the cost and the
amount of human suffering we're bound to
see
we need to explore new ways of producing
food like vertical farming
we should greenify our existing
buildings and set strict guidelines for
new ones
we need to develop a plan for those
communities displaced by climate change
and work towards providing housing and
jobs for our friends and neighbors
ideally in a new climate mitigation
sector we're all in the path of this
oncoming car
and whatever you think the reason is
that we're in danger i think we can all
agree that we need to step out of the
way
if you've watched my last few videos
you'll have noticed that youtube has
been demonetizing a lot of them
that's why some of my creator friends
and i teamed up to build nebula a
streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization since nebula is all about
creating thoughtful content we've
partnered with curiositystream an
established streaming platform with a
solid track record of caring about great
educational content and the financial
security of those who produce it
curiosity stream is an online streaming
service with thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game you can find tons of great
episodes like climate change by the
numbers which is a fantastic watch if
you enjoyed this video
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiosity stream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free for a limited time curiosity stream
is offering 26
off their annual plan that's less than
15 bucks a year for both curiosity
stream and nebula which in my humble
opinion is a pretty great deal
since we're all stuck inside anyway why
not spend some time learning about
climate change on curiosity stream
or check out the original content from
all your favorite creators on nebula
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
follow the link below to sign up now if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more like it consider subscribing to
stay up to date with my latest episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week